on April 26  [Music]  you know teams in our missions  no mistakes no do-overs  look out for each other  [Music]  this is the fight of our lives  he's pretty good at that right  adventures and gay rated pg-13 tickets  on sale now infinity war was nuts  but this one is going to be your finest  hour we're in the endgame  then I was wiped out 50% of all living  creatures these are the highest Sikhs  that the Avengers have ever faced this  is the fight of our lives this is good  work Steve I know it is cuz I don't know  what I'm gonna do if it doesn't  everything you think marbles pulled  every single trick out of the bag  they actually saved the best stuff for  this one this is the end of the firework  show the grand finale soit Elia is  insane you just don't know what to  expect  I guarantee you there is no way anybody  could guess what's gonna happen  where's the Avengers we gotta finish  this  tickets on sale now  you